all right here we are number time the
Executive Vice President of the center
for international policy Matt D and the
columnist of CH magazine Jamie kch here
are the things people want to know what
explains Israel's intelligence failure
yes we never got to that why I mean wow
I mean Netanyahu was always the security
guy I mean people oh he's an but
he's our and he's going to keep
us safe and Israel was always his main
argument yes and always great at this
kind of stuff and they have to be they
live in the roughest neighborhood in the
world how did this happen
great well I think there was the
operational level where they took out
some sensors right and somehow the
Israelis didn't see that but I think
there was a larger strategic picture
where they really did not think that
Hamas would attempt something like this
they thought that Hamas was something
that amamas they could they could sort
of deal with them in some way but they
would they were letting in guest workers
they were letting in guest workers
thatas would not be so irrational or
suicidal whatever word you want to use
to actually perpetrate something yeah I
mean I would make two points here one is
just to understand the scope of the the
intelligence failure here we're talking
about I think it's some 1500 Hamas
fighters who were killed inside Israel
you had probably another 500 more who
took the hostages back into Gaz we're
talking at least 2,000 people right um
that's a lot of people talking to keep
secret that's a lot yes exactly right
the the idea that Israeli intelligence
could not figure this out or know that
something was going on but also the
second point you know I made reference
to this the settlements to to benir um
and Israeli security officials and
others have suggested that one of the
problems that you had a lot of Israeli
security redeployed to the West Bank to
protect settler groups for the purposes
of promoting settlements attacking
Palestinians and that left the fence
line relatively undefended which also
suggests that Hamas themselves may have
been shocked at how easy it was to cross
the river also I may say too many Jewish
holidays a lot
of I'm I'm that oneide a lot of the as a
CHR Jewish holidays I disagree a lot a
lot of the soldiers were like on leave
and you know so was 50 years to to the
day of the you think they would see that
coming yeah it's like L garri and luk
G's disease right I
know what are the odds what are the
odds okay uh will Ohio representative
Jim
Jordan this is this is hysterical what's
going on and if it wasn't our Congress
I'd laugh harder but win enough votes to
become speaker how does having a speaker
of the house impact military aid I'm
actually more concerned can someone get
this guy a gift certificate to Brooks
Brothers yeah
right
seriously I
mean politicians have always done the
shirt sleeve rolled up but not
always just when you're trying to make a
point and like I'm a man of the people
but sometimes you have a job jacking on
yeah okay but now again I may have this
recap wrong but he was the choice at the
beginning of the week end Trump couldn't
get the because Trump endorsed him last
week I heard it was going to be Trump
himself because because this is crazy in
America you don't have to be a member of
Congress to be the speaker of the house
right shouldn't
you it's is that not a law we should
have and then Trump realized that you
have to do stuff right it does involve
actual work oh a lot of work yes but
okay so then they went to Steve scales
Steve scales the guy he was you know
hard right winger from Louisiana David
Duke without the baggage as he described
that's in his own words he said that
David Duke without the baggage I guess
that that little word baggage is doing a
lot in that in that phrase
there baggage is that's a little that's
when you can't even get it closed you
know you're just trying to get the
suit uh yes but uh and now they're back
as of by the time this goes on the air
it'll probably be be stale but now
wether back to Jim Jordan who the former
gym
teacher I call him like like like Dennis
H the former wrestling coach wrestling
well he was an assistant wrestling coach
right yeah he Wasim I call him Jim Jim
Jordan yes and uh you know obviously
some very troubling allegations in his
past what obviously some very troubling
allegations in his past about you know
what they said you know they those who
can't teach teach
Jim and those who can't those who can't
teach Jim become speaker of the
house so
girl that's but that's true the the the
other gym teacher who was the Speaker of
the House Dennis hter yeah he was a
child molester right yeah convicted okay
this guy is not a child molester but he
did Let It Go On
that is the allegation yes that's the
allegation okay we just allegedly that
he knew about it but didn't do anything
to stop it right kind of like you know
he was Joe pno to Jerry
sanduski yep
that's sorry did that depress you
uh uh now that Bob bendeez another but
who boy the guy with the gold bars in
his jacket this this this he was just
this farup chart this foreign agent
registry charge will he be yeah I mean
which is an addition to the bribery
which is pretty amazing because I mean
working in Washington and James probably
knows it's like to run a foul of Farah
the foreign agents registration act you
have to want to get caught these are so
loosely forced and I just as with this
as with the bribery charge when you read
what he actually did it's like Menendez
was like challenge
accepted you know I am going to be so
blatant and SLO
okay uh will the US right to freeze
access to the six billion in funds it
transferred to Iran as part of the
prisoner deal we negotiated or was the
US right to freeze that we negotiated
last month okay so if people don't know
we wanted to get how many people back
five five we got them back we we got
them back and we paid six billion we
didn't pay it it was money that Ukraine
okay no it was Iran's money from oil
that had been okay but we made the deal
we got the people back and now we're not
giving them the
money I mean I'm
not I'm I'm not I'm not taking a ran
side in this but you know we did have a
deal I mean we have a history of
breaking deals with Iran unfortunately
but the charge was made that you know I
think Tim Scott and others made this
completely demagogic you know false
claim that you know this money helped to
fund the attacks we saw last weekend
which is absurd for a number of reasons
not least of which is this none of this
money had been dispersed yet they
haven't seen a but there's a larger
point that we should have maintained the
pressure campaign on Iran that the Trump
Administration started and that that was
rolled and dialed back by the Biden
Administration and it has allowed really
not true they've kept in almost every
element the Trump no they what we should
have done is deal Obama made that's
exactly what we should have done no way
no no way
IR this this Iranian regime how can you
make a deal with this Iranian if you
have a deal that keeps them away from a
nuclear weapon make that deal
and they did and they Obama made that
deal it I mean it was like this is with
the sunset cause of 12 Years okay so we
just postponed by 12 years the date that
they got a nuclear weapon okay well
nothing no deal is perfect isn't that
what we're saying about the Palestinians
the West Bank they could have had their
own country many times not many times
but a few times certainly there deal
taken and didn't right they could have
had 97% of the West Bank but they it was
not perfect as no deal is because Israel
was not about to give it to them just
say oh you know what do your thing they
were like yes we have to keep an eye on
you for very good reason but over time
if they had taken that deal where would
the world be today in 2023 if there had
been a a if Arafat had taken that deal
and in 200 the wiard day yes then you
show Israel we're not out somehow we got
back to Israel Palestine uh from
okay um but I'll just get back to the
Iran deal uh for a minute I think
important to understand about this this
6 billion is that it was going to be is
handled and held by Qatar and was going
to be spent by Qatar on specific
humanitarian items so there's it's not
like it's not like we're giving Iran
under strict monitor but money is
fungible money is fungible and money
that can go to paying for humanitarian
Goods can be also used on it's not as if
and listen as they say the military eats
first right so Iran has not been even
though they under some of the heaviest
sanction in the world they still have
not been you know they still have money
to spend on their military and all their
you know their nefarious activities this
is just giving money to actually help
their people again not defending this
regime no one should but I think let's
understand the nature of this six
billion and what is going to be I got
one last question I've been hearing a
lot this week that Nikki Haley is really
kicking ass that she's rising up in the
Republican party there she is and and uh
I see George Wills column says uh Tim
Scott should bow out of the race throw
his support to Nikki Haley encourage
everybody else in the race to do the
same thing that this is the viable
alternative to Donald Trump and
and and if we just had a
race if we just had a republican race
with just two people and Nikki haly was
the alternative it's possible that she
would take it from Trump there's a
chance there's a chance and I thought
she did great in the first debate not as
good in the second debate but look he
has over 50% Trump does now now and yeah
if it was just two people per she she
would have a fighting chance and yes I
would absolutely that all the other
Republicans running now need to do their
patriotic Duty and do what they didn't
do the last time and they need to Rally
behind one anti-trump alternative and
she yeah I don't know we'll
see you know if
you if you remember you know Trump has
not really taken her on yet he he's
waiting if if you remember from you know
Lord of the Rings um you know the the
Eye of
Sauron on once the once the eye of trump
turns to Nikki Haley with all this
withering power all right thank you guys
I appreciate it thank
you